the jurogan experience the thing about
redheads i read this thing where it said
that redheads have uh like
something about pain
that they uh have a higher tolerance for
pain they think it might actually be a
genetic thing irish yeah
like see if we can find that there was
something about redheads and pain
yeah they get [ __ ]
is linked between red hair and pain
threshold wow
they're the chosen ones british rule be
like a redheaded stepchild find out
let's find louie and start punching him
oh he can take it i bet he can so it
says people with red hair have a variant
a normal man would have killed himself a
long time ago oh yeah
i'm saying he's got paint threshold i
heard his new special is [ __ ] amazing
show i heard it's amazing and that
[ __ ] sign behind him that just says
sorry you were there for it i was just
with him i was on the road with him oh
yes
i did get him to do an instagram yeah
he just got like i was like you got to
get back in and then i think he already
deleted it ah as soon as i left the tory
the little [ __ ]
well you know
he's you know he's the beloved guy and
then also they turned on him
i heard his new set is amazing that's
what i heard
all right i'll tell you a cool story
he's gonna be mad this is it's i don't
want to don't get the guy in more
trouble no it's just a funny thing i got
to the hotel
and he was like
what are you doing i was like i'm gonna
i forgot my sunglasses i'm gonna go buy
a pair of sunglasses he was like all
right i want you to come to my hotel
room before you leave and i was like no
of course he knew he was [ __ ] with me
he was when the doors were closing he
was like i'm not going to jerk off
but i probably shouldn't have said that
on here that's all right
he's the king and uh
what he wanted to show me was that some
of that
that he filmed and then i saw the hour
and it's like i heard it
can not wait what did he say he already
filmed it yeah yeah
the hulu right yeah when is it coming
out i'm not sure
that's a little awkward though that he
showed you that
i got it yeah i should have said that
story i know i get it yeah um
he and i talked about doing the podcast
twice
delete the story now we're
he's a great guy what's wrong with that
story that wasn't bad
you didn't say anything bad about him i
got a bad louis story so i used to open
for him before he was in trouble
and uh you know he was like the king of
comedy for a while he was the funniest
guy ever you know whatever so i used to
open for him it was the highlight of my
life and then we were hanging out in his
hotel room watching a a movie and we
were talking and i was sitting on his
bed and he was sitting at the chair in
the hotel room and i go hey louie and i
farted on his bed on his bed
he lost it he flipped i was like you're
like the filthy comedy guy i thought you
would love a fart and he was like dude
what are you doing oh
i was crushed but did he get actually
angry or just like that dude what are
you doing it was worse because it was
like i'm disappointed in you like i
thought we were building a relationship
and you fart
i could see that 100 oh
he strikes me as a guy that would yeah
oh yeah
i could see him going both ways
interesting i could see him going like
that was hilarious or like hey dude i
caught him
and it was a great fart too i really
thought he would be like oh [ __ ] watch
the entire episode for free only on
spotify